what about production insurance and like
what what's the normal deductible and I
mean I know nothing about production so
it just depends on how much you want to
pay so if I pay $7,000 for insurance
it's probably about twenty five hundred
dollar deductible okay I can pay more
and have a thousand dollars a bunch of
all this depends on the project because
each project based on what's involved in
it the insurance are different and
what's the term for the so the the term
would be for the term of the production
right so so if it's a four week thing
and you go over how do you then renew
the insurance right don't know I'm gonna
do like a like physical forward shoot
doesn't normally do like a - like a two
month policy oh that's pretty much
policy which it covers through prep and
all the way through post-production
okay and then if you needed to do any
reshoots would unless it was in that
time period you'd have to then renew it
yes yeah during ain't anytime during
production we can always extend it I can
even they it doesn't really cost I think
how much more money just to say we want
to do it for six months versus three
months and there's some companies that
just constantly carry production
insurance they just always have it which
makes it nice and easy but we usually
tend to do because each production is
its own LLC we usually cover that LLC
separately so then are you involved in
getting the paperwork to the Secretary
of State or whoever to do the articles
of incorporation and all that if you
have an attorney do that uh some
sometimes have an attorney to do it
sometimes we just uh place in Burbank at
school I forgot the name of it but they
know your self legal type they give them
everything and then like 24 hours like
they they were here 48 hours like here
you go okay which is nice so I really
not have to deal with all that sure
what's going on Siri do we normally have
someone just do it for us okay and so
then once the LLC is established then
that entity lives on and
it covers the film yeah once we
establish the LLC it just pretty it is
it's just forever going and so you have
to pay the taxes on it and Shaun do all
the fun stuff after that paperwork
paperwork at the end of the year and
reconcile everything and but that's why
I'm a production accountants they do all
that for us they enjoy all that yeah
here you go let me know how it is yeah
which is uh we're running a little lower
budget production and Larry night my
business partner try to uh yeah we could
do all that we did it but never again
it's just it's just too much work so
this and one thing about us because we
know how we know how to do everything
it's just we have to prevent ourselves
from going yeah yeah yeah we can do that
because we'll take on too much and you
know because we can and it just is
that's how we get exhausted and because
we don't take a little too much and it's
it's better to have a fresh someone
dedicated to that one job that can just
stay without one job and stays fresh and
we all don't all get burnt out sure and
speaking of burnout what do you do to
renew yourself and how much time do you
give yourself between projects um it
depends I've come by me and uh in Utah
we shot those two films back-to-back and
so we had like a week break however
because we were in production the week
was not really a break for us because we
were still in the office working so we
had two days off in between but but
typically after a show is done I'll take
a week and let's go got a week to go do
whatever and sometimes I stay at home
and just relax and get caught up and
sometimes I'm gonna match your mountain
and sometimes I would see my parents in
Vegas and sometimes dog take your trip
to see friends somewhere so just fence
you